any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
so
everybody it is a delight to welcome
a friend who's known me
pretty much my whole life uh maybe even
before i was born i don't know
and that's dr marilyn uh simons uh who
is now currently
i think she's unemployed i mean you were
the president of the simon's foundation
uh and were speaking in december right
after you received the highest honor
awarded to uh to human beings by the uh
french government called the leshon the
on-air now marilyn i got a c minus in
high school french like 30 years ago so
please don't hold me to account i know
you've been practicing but first of all
how are you doing today uh marilyn and
congratulations
um i'm doing great today it's great to
see you and be here with you brian
and um one comment
i was never officially employed by the
simon's foundation as a donor that would
kind of make me
have a conflict of interest but i was
did have the title of president but
never
received a salary right and now i'm in
the same position for our private
foundation
so
in the same employed not employed role
and when i think about you the first
thing that comes to mind is curiosity
when i think about all the different
things you're so interested in i'll
relate a very quick story when we were
in chile in 2019 to do the
groundbreaking for the simon's
observatory
you after we were up at 17 200 feet you
scampered up there almost from sea level
by yourself like a like a lovely
mountain goat uh when you got there uh
you did the groundbreaking better than
the strapping young men we were with um
and then we came down we did some late
night observations of the heavens using
optical telescopes and it was really
delightful for me to get to show you you
know everything that's been my childhood
passion and i thought i could impress
upon you you know how much i know about
astronomy since you knew me as a kid and
there you are looking at jupiter and
telling me all the names of the moons
and all the names of the of the
different objects we were seeing and i
was like i can't even i can't even like
one-up her in this she has to beat me in
crossword puzzles and and it was it was
frustrating but i i do want to commend
you on this this radical curiosity that
you have and i want to start maybe with
your beginning um uh after we get into
what the legion the honor means let's
talk about that it was last given it has
been given to people like alexander
fleming and jane goodall who's a hero of
mine uh what is the legional donor and
what does it mean to you when you won it
well the latino donor actually was an
award that was started by napoleon
to recognize people
for their service to france
so it's a really high honor
and there are different levels of being
um in
recognized
and i found out that i was immediately
promoted to level two so i'm an officer
in malaysia now
and um
well a funny story about how i first
learned about this
jim and i had a friend and he was always
making up stories and
pulling our leg and he came to our house
for dinner and over cocktails
i told him
that i thought that the dry cleaning
company must have left a staple
on his lapel
and
he said to me
he explained to me that that was not a
staple
it was an award
from france and he was recognized by the
as a member of the legion of honor
but of course i thought he was totally
pulling my leg
um but it turns out it was true
and
so
that's when i first learned about it
and um
you know you might wonder why what was
my service to france
and
aside from being a francophile like so
many of us around the world
um it has been for the work of the
simon's foundation and our support of
basic science research and mathematics
and many of whom
are many of our grantees are french
citizens and even many of our
researchers at the flatiron institute
come from france
they have a remarkable
culture and emphasis on research and
science and math so
naturally when you want to find the very
best people and fields many of them are
in france yes
yes very much uh
quite an inspiring country for many
reasons and and not the least of which
is their dedication to you know pure
science which is what i think about not
necessarily applied and looking for
things although some things come from
some technological benefits do come from
pure research from fundamental research
but as you
got
the word of this notification did you
feel any kind of pressure you know i
only know about losing things like
losing the nobel prize
did you feel when you saw the list of
people including jane goodall and
alexander fleming and um emmanuel sharp
and ta would were you intimidated at all
was it was it sort of nerve-wracking or
did you take it with your uh ordinary
well-known sense of marilyn simon's
aplomb
one can help but figure
um
assess if you really are deserving
but um
when i spoke to the people at the
institute desoto
scientifique
which we call ihes
one thing that was explained to me is
you know there are not a lot of women in
philanthropy making big gifts
and most especially
supporting basic science and mathematics
so they
definitely
wanted to recognize
my role and support of basic science and
math and by the way
brian one thing that i learned going
into the awards ceremony
talking about french culture
in paris there are over 80 streets that
are named after mathematicians
we just don't have anything like that in
our culture
so i think we could all learn
from and try to emulate their respect
for the work being done there yeah and
even in um even in
other countries much smaller countries
take new zealand uh the new zealand i
think it's the five pound five dollar
note or ten dollar note has ernest
rutherford uh who did most of his
discoveries on the nucleus while he was
in the uk but he is on their you know
one of their most uh used uh currency uh
bills and i think it's uh it's quite
striking that how prominent other
nations make their scientists and and
and and so forth i actually had the
honor of presenting an award to michio
kaku um at the uh at the french embassy
in in washington dc last month in
november uh for the arthur c clarke
foundation and i'm affiliated with them
and in the french embassy i was just
blown away on they had a whole an
enormous hall dedicated to marie curie
and and her amazing discoveries in
radium and transformative ideas about
science and it seems to me they were
really kind of ahead of the time both in
their science and their promotion of
science but also in women in science and
i think that's a topic that that is near
and dear to your heart
is not only supporting women in science
which you do exceptionally well but
being a role model and i want to go back
to your
upbringing and to your career as an
economist and obtaining your phd
first of all do you consider economics a
science is it a science they they call
it economic sciences and the nobel prize
for for uh this field but do you
consider it a type of science or is
there more like uh psychology in a sense
well it is human related
so it's a what's called the social
science
it's
harder to do experiments the way
you know when we think of science we
think of empirical
and
rational
deduction
of
to get a better understanding of the
world around us
and i would say that economics is
striving to move in that direction
no there but
um
it's clearly there's a difference it
doesn't have
that we know a fundamental laws
that will govern
outcome although
problem you know there are some there's
fundamentally
supply and demand
and um but it's a work in progress
yes indeed so talk about your i don't
think i've ever heard you talk about
your thesis work um when you were a
graduate student at stony brook um what
was your title of your thesis and what
drew you to economics in the first place
first of all in the 1970s
it wasn't so common for women
to be in that field it was a very much
male dominated field in fact i think
it's the least
gender balanced of all the nobel prize i
think only one woman has won the nobel
prize in economics i may be mistaken um
of course it's the newest of all those
nobel prize but at any rate what
impelled you to take on this field um
of interest and and how does it relate
to your you know early childhood kind of
upbringing and exposure from a
middle-class family in long island
how did you go pivot from from that
upbringing to something so erudite and
and uh enticing but not normally the
choice of a woman in those times i
understand it
so
a couple of things first
growing up i grew up in the cold war and
i was always hearing about communism i
remember playing with all the other kids
on my block and one day we were all
playing in
hawaii tart blends
um
rock pile
smashing rocks and a flame a plane flew
overhead oh howie jackson it was a plane
flew overhead and somebody looked up and
said i hope that's not a russian plane
and that's when i learned about the
russians and the cold war from the other
kids
so communism always fascinated me and
also
you know you said i grew up middle class
i grew up middle middle class
and everybody in my family was a
bricklayer my father was a brick
subcontractor
and
i knew
times were good times were bad and i
remember one day my dad came home from
work and he went right to sleep and i
asked my mom what was the matter with my
dad
and she said oh he's depressed business
is bad
so i think you know just my childhood
experiences
made me want to understand this part of
the world around me the political threat
of communism and the real threat to our
family
when times were bad
and um
you know i also went to get girls school
and i think also the ideals that i
learned in catholicism
i think also made
some ideas and socialism very appealing
to take care of everyone
and think more about equity
so
and my mom mentioned that you
you wanted to be a sarina at one point
is that
i did have a love of russian culture too
i was curious and my own background and
my father's side in the family is polish
so um but they spoke russian because it
was controlled by russia
so anyway
when i went off to college i started
studying first i took a course in
marxist economics and then i took a
course in microeconomics
but as to the male female
ratio
that to me i was used to being with all
girls so now when i was with all boys
that was great i didn't know what boys
were like i'd been in catholic girls
school since i was eight years old to
18.
i'd only had nuns as teachers
so
it was pretty interesting to me to have
boys in my class and have male teachers
and i remember at one point looking
around the class thinking
that
i wasn't like anybody else in the class
but then having this other thought
that popped into my head i guess we all
love thinking about economics
so that was the end of my worrying about
being different
and
it was fun to make so life was averaging
out
and i was i really liked
microeconomics
i always liked math when i went to
school my school didn't teach a lot of
science it had the basics for new york
state and the basics for math but after
i finished trigonometry and high school
there was no more math and so actually
in my senior year
i took a correspondence course with the
university of nebraska
and i'd have to go to study hall and do
my problem sets
and they get sent off to nebraska to be
graded
and
that was a funny experience
but i'm just sharing that that
i i liked math as a kid
and um i really liked
microeconomics it was
more mathematical
so
um when i did my dissertation i really
loved auction theory
and i did my work on optimal bidding
strategies
so
optimal bidding strategies and
multi-object auctions like the treasury
bill auctions
i looked at what was the revenue
to the seller in this case the treasury
under different
gain formulations of the rules
and my husband jim
taught me the calculus of variations
so that i could
derive these optimal bidding strategies
but um
you know i
i really
haven't continued with that research i
always say that i went from being a
theoretical
micro economist to being a very applied
running our foundation right yeah it's
it is you know a full-time job for for
many people
uh and just doing it as you did for so
long
um you know required these tools i'm
sure uh and and actual application not
as you say not just theoretically
and when you think about the kind of
structure the relationship between pure
math
and connection to a social organization
like the foundation i'm curious and in
terms of leadership you might have some
ideas grounded in theory uh but you know
they as they say you know communism
works in theory but not in practice or
so how do you convey
that you know to an organization that
you're the leader of how do you convey
that you know there is a better way or
perhaps there's a different approach um
you know when everybody's kind of doing
everything for the first time i mean
that was the first time the foundation
ever existed and you were leading it in
this capacity how do you convince people
you know when when you're starting from
scratch it's so hard to begin something
anew how do you convince them to listen
to you to take what you're saying you
know with the proper amount of attention
that it deserves
that's a good question and i'm sure
something that you think about with your
own work at the simon's observatory
um i think having a really strong team
around me
so that it isn't just what do i say but
also having
incredible
visionaries and
and
leaders who are working together with me
it's never just one person who makes a
difference it's a
team that makes a critical mass
and
you know getting input from people who
are
terrific thinkers themselves
you can come up with a plan and when i
talk about our foundation i always say
that we
evolved you know it grew
just as you've experienced with your own
observatory right your project grew
and you have to grow and adapt and go to
the next level
and um we were always
looking to get to that next level
but
i just think it's the critical mass of
people that you have around you
that builds confidence and you just work
so well together
yeah and sometimes i feel like you know
with with folks that are so brilliant in
one field like i work with the most
brilliant
astrophysicists scientists computer
scientists
etc etc engineers um and yet we don't
spend that much time thinking about
management and organization and
principles of of a culture of success um
because it's it's actually perceived
that that's hard in other words if i ask
a brilliant
national academy you know member of our
team you know why doesn't you know he or
she
you know
like do they do they pay any attention
to best practices and management
leadership oh that's really hard i'm
like oh yeah yeah because quantum
electrodynamics is so easy you know
everybody comes out of the womb and they
know no though i had to work on that and
i guess one of the challenges i'm
curious to your approach on how do you
convince somebody who is extremely well
developed in one side of the brain i
always forget which side of the brain
controls the quantitative side and i'm
sure that makes me the other side of the
brain but um but how do you convince
them to take that side series in other
words the interpersonal skills the
persuasion there's an awful lot of
salesmanship even in science to get your
papers accepted and and do sorts of
various things and and to champion your
brand how do you cultivate that in an
organization when again it's ab initio
it's new no one's ever done what you did
before how do you convince someone who's
brilliant quantitative
that the soft skills are also equally
important if not more important
you know that's why you have to have a
team approach
i mean
i
i think
you know i worked really closely with my
husband jim
and jim is very
focused on getting the job done and
being gold directed
and um but we also had people on the
team who really focused on communication
and
you know i think
we built it in and
when somebody
just say that you have a diversity of
needs and voices and messages that you
need to deliver
we got everyone to at least accept
that
there was such a thing as best practices
and that we were
we that's the direction we were headed
and brian i got to hear somebody
outstanding that you've added to your
project i think his name is gary
yeah
so he it seems to me that you have a
team member that you added who's a real
voice
for culture and communication
and strategic building of your project
and
you know people will listen when
the message is delivered clearly
so
yeah and i think you know that comes
down to kind of um
conveying a sense of authority in a good
sense like you're an authority on
something not like you're gonna do what
i tell you to do and i always wonder
well how do you know somebody's in
authority like how do you know someone's
an expert you should look um according
to ray dalio who's you know i know is
friendly with jim um you know he says
well an expert is someone who's done
a thing three times successfully you
know it could be a telescope it could be
starting a company or managing a fund or
uh laboratories etc they've done it you
know three different levels and i kind
of see that in our educational system
first you get your graduate school you
know degree then you get your you work
as a postdoctoral scholar or fellow and
then you're a young assistant lab leader
and then then you kind of establish this
pedigree
of leadership
but you know i always think there's got
to be a better way you know how how do
we you know the how do we inculcate the
values and the culture to know
you know i need a team and a lot of us
are type a we want to do it all
ourselves and we want
and to resist that urge and it's really
refreshing to see that you've had these
three different careers and and you're
probably gonna have more careers
um and and i wonder i know it's an
unfair question but i have to ask it
like do you have a favorite you know i
always ask my mom you know as you know
my mom and i'll say you know who's your
favorite kid come on it's me right
that's like asking me you know which
hand is bet my favorite my left or my
right and i say mom you are left-handed
you know it's
um so do you have like of the different
careers you know from economics to
philanthropy to you know board of
directors cold spring heart all the
things that you've done
um is there one in particular that that
really just you don't need any
additional inspiration it always excites
you or are they truly like my mom's
claim i don't believe her but uh that
they're all like your fingers or your
hands yeah they're equally important to
you
you know i think that i've grown and
been able to do different things at
different points in my life
and so i feel now that
i'm at a place where i get to integrate
a lot of the knowledge that i
i learned previously
so i don't think i could answer that
question but for a different reason
because
i couldn't have started out doing what
i'm doing now
i love
like
seeing the whole picture
i'll give you an example
i my niece likes
acting
and she would talk about like liking to
be an actress and i would say
well what about being the person who
pulls it all together
like seeing every role that's going
part of it you know the screenwriting
the
acting the selling and
you know getting the support for the
film
and you know i like those kind of
questions i found it interesting as i
got older to be able to see
a bigger picture and and look at the way
all the parts are interacting i'm sure
you that's your experience at the
simon's observatory too yeah
yeah and learning from the best in the
world the best engineers and i i think
it's it's it's helped me that i am
curious i think like you and and that i
love learning even about learning and i
love learning even about management you
know so i um i want to use this as an
opportunity to pivot to a different
direction so every day
i read
a couple of books i actually read a
portion from the bible i know that
surprises many of my scientist
colleagues the weekly torah portion i
read that but i also read ancient you
know christian philosophy you know
stoicism and i read something about
business because you know a book by like
i said ray dalio or gordon moore
or uh or rather andy grove books like
that really inspired because it's a
completely different wiring of the brain
and a different way to think about being
effective as an executive of uh of this
project in my laboratory i want to ask
you marilyn do you have a routine
besides you know crossword puzzles you
know in uh we'll get to that later but
uh besides doing the the daily mini
crossword puzzle which i think i might
have turned you on to um by the way are
you doing word scapes yet have you taken
my latest advice i have not but i've
gotten really good at spilling big yes
oh spelling bee is great i was a queen
bee twice
this week
so wow you can add that to your cv
because i know you'll be uh you're on
the job market you're looking hard for
employment gainfully tell me do you have
uh
daily routines rituals habits do you
think those are important or weekly ones
and obviously family is is first to you
uh but do you have like a daily routine
and you know i know you exercise a lot
what is your day like what does your day
look like i know you're wearing an aura
ring like i am so you must be kind of
tracking things right um yeah tell me do
you um i i was joking to somebody
marilyn i said i got the aura ring and
they're like oh yeah i just got the new
one the gold one i said oh yeah i got
the invisible one you see that
that's the generation four but what is
your daily routine like um if you care
to share it well over coffee in the
morning i like to wake up with a
spelling bee
um i am lately
learning french on duolingo
so
i try to do that a little bit in the
morning be
while um like while i'm
brushing my teeth and fixing my hair
i'll do the
conversational parts
but then i get to work
and i wish i could tell you that i was
read i had a regular amount that i read
i don't
because i have a very bad habit
that when i'm really enjoying what i'm
reading
i
can't stop
so
when i start a book if i like it i can't
stop
so i really kind of time my
personal reading
to when i'm taking vacation or i really
have the time to
lose myself in a book um
so otherwise
it's just the articles i like reading
quantum magazine
and
but i always have a pile of reading that
i want to get to
so
it's next to my bed it's on my desk so
i have all my shorter articles on my
desk so when i have a chance to read i
will
so
it's um
you know i look forward to vacation time
so i can immerse myself in something
and
so
and i like crossword puzzles as you said
and then in the evening
i can really relax and get competitive
with duolingo and make sure that i
get my points for the day so i stay in
the diamond link
that's the uh called gamification you
can turn
habits
into rewards mechanisms and the human
brain releases a little dopamine when
you do something good and uh yeah maybe
we can pivot to it to another topic this
is i asked jim when he was on last year
um and it has to do with maybe you know
how you spend your time how you spend
your attention you know people say the
the most precious resource is time and i
agree with that uh but i asked him you
know another precious resource is money
and i asked jim you know what is the
purpose of wealth where do you see
wealth as as as you know philosophically
does it mean anything does it mean you
know oh money is not important no i
think it is and um what's your
philosophy of philanthropy and of wealth
in general because as i told jim you
know you can have a big boat but you can
only have one of them you can't water
ski behind two yachts at the same time
um so he he said you know he he
definitely appreciates it he likes the
benefits of the wealth but it's for him
it's a it's a type of tool but i'm
curious what is wealth to you
so i would definitely say it's
opportunity
as you're saying there's only so
so much you could get
and if i am going out and buying gifts
for people or going shopping for new
dress for myself i make the joke that
i'm going out to stimulate the economy
practical of microeconomics
yes but
you know having wealth i i see the
business model you invest you
earn income and that's an income stream
that you can use to support the things
you really care about
so
um
i've tried to really look for impact
and evolve in my thinking
but i think that's what it is the
opportunity to have an impact and
try
to make the world a little bit better
you wish you could make it a lot better
you wish you could make a lot of things
a lot better but to focus and really try
to bring about some positive change
and i want to also uh extend a
commendation to how great you are at
getting gifts and actually i want to
pivot that to a question uh some people
are curious about um have you do you
have a specific book let's just focus on
books that you've given as a gift
very frequently in your life and career
is there is there one book or maybe a
couple of books that you find you want
to share so much with other people and
that you give it to them as a gift
besides my book my books
i know you give out those one
well
it's hard for me to tell like i'm
older now so
i can most
i can best remember
the latest book that really had an
impact on me yeah and that
is a book called the choice
and i'd have to look up the author's
name
but
it's a woman about a woman who
survived auschwitz
and
she um came here to the u.s and became a
psychoanalyst
and ultimately
worked on her whole life in thinking
about
and this is what she's talking about
that things happen in our lives but we
can choose
how they impact us and how we move
forward through them
and it's a remarkable story of her own
resiliency
and it's really inspiring and i have
given that
book out in my family
and um
we're hoping to have a little book club
session to talk about that with each
other oh wow
that's great yeah i asked jim the same
question and he had given me advice a
book his favorite book do you know what
jim's favorite book is by the way or
most gifted book
no it's called the captain it's about a
uh sea captain i think in the early part
of world war ii
uh on a transport ship um but it's very
uh it's semi-non uh semi-fictional
although it's based on this true life
story of you know these transport boats
during world war ii anyway i found that
fascinating because it's really a book
about that's a stealth leadership book
it talks about you know leading this
this group under extreme duress and
challenges etc um
so you spoke a little bit about
mathematics and and economics um i want
to take uh just a quick detour to the
year i was born 1971 50 years ago um you
were came into the picture a little bit
after that but at least in my personal
uh history my universe
but in that year that was the year the
u.s went off the gold standard and a lot
of economists i've listened to correlate
that with the necessity not just the
optionality but the necessity of women
entering the workforce in many different
fields and i wonder you know is there a
perspective on that you can give to
young women i have a lot of young women
that listen to the show um you know how
do you balance how did you balance your
careers plural
and raising your children um amidst you
know all the other activities that you
had to do um obviously you didn't have
to it wasn't like you know inflation
caused you to have to you know pick up a
second job although you weren't you know
jim's really sick financial success
didn't take off until much later i would
say right um
but uh but you know how how do you
balance that what advice do you give to
women that are struggling between you
know raising a family doing a job being
having a life
you know we always leave that out you
know they need friends just like anybody
else they need uh distractions they need
uh respite and personal how do you what
advice do you give to women nowadays do
you think it's getting better or um or
do you think there's still a lot more we
can do specifically in the sciences
so
i can't say that i had a wonderful
master plan
or that
i didn't also
struggle and talk with my friends
as we struggled
to
find
a
reasonable balance between
being moms
and also
having the stimulation
of being involved in the workforce and
being with our
peers every day
so
i
you know i
responded to the needs of our family
of
my family at the time
so
i
did get my phd
and
i did
have child care and i actually at that
time
so
i guess i started
school somewhere around 76 or 78
something like that
i didn't
i managed to fill in the form and get a
green card
for the lady who was working for me
because
it didn't occur to me to go to a lawyer
to ask for help getting a green card
so i actually
totally qualified for getting
uh and
employing somebody who didn't have a
green card so that worked out that fell
into place and i worked at home on my
dissertation
and
yolanda really helped me with child's
care
and
but um
when my daughter was born
um i she def she needed to go to therapy
for extra help
and
i felt like my family really needed me
and that i needed to take her to therapy
and it would be hard to have a part-time
job as an economist
and so my life took a different track
than i had expected
but there was a need
and um
it turned out jim was very supportive of
my getting involved in
profits he liked the idea that somebody
in the family
was um doing
volunteer work and i went on my first
board
and that kind of worked out really well
for me
because i had
time a block of time or i could be
project oriented rather than full-time
work
so
i a couple of boards i realize i love
the budget and finance committee
i really like you know thinking about
how to make a not-for-profit of
successful business
how to raise money for it
so
as jim started to
be successful in his business that's
what made me say
hey why don't we start our own
foundation
and
we didn't have we had a lot of money by
our standards then we started with a
million dollars
and the foundation was just me i like to
say that
um
this all has a bottom line that answers
your question
so let me give the spoiler alert
the spoiler alert is
i responded from up to need
i i then i was lucky to find
opportunities
and as my time
allowed
my opportunities kind of evolved into
more than i ever imagined
so that's the spoiler alert
so you know i said to j i say to people
when i talk about our foundation
unlike bill gates or warren buffett we
didn't first make a fortune and then
decide to give it away
we started small
and it grew it grew faster than we
imagined
and we just kind of adapted and went
with the change and
that's how the foundation happened and
it was a surprise
so i was lucky so
i think that
bottom line
and maybe this ties back
to my school motto
from catholic girls school
just
looking for opportunities
taking chances going to trying out
something new
and
just making the most of it so my school
motto when i was a kid
was
i am only one but i am one i can't do
everything but i can do something
and what i can do
i ought to do and what i ought to do by
the grace of god i will do
so
you know i've
you know that's i think
something that has guided me it's a
paraphrase of something by someone
who's
i think his name is hale h-a-l-a maybe
his first name is everett
but it
you know just kind of taught me if i see
something that needs to be done
i try to do it
so
yeah so
yes
it kind of dovetails nicely into our
our final
segments where we uh do discuss the
existential questions of life we'll get
to that in a second but the last
um topic for the main segment of our
conversation has to do with philanthropy
specifically in science and i remember
an article in the new york times you
know kind of decrying well you know
should these billionaires have so much
influence in scientific funding
and i remember you just stopped that you
know kind of dead in its tracks and and
you stated that what are the unique
benefits of of private versus public and
how private compares to public funding
so maybe you can recapitulate that
what's your response to somebody who
says oh you know it's not fair that
elon musk and jeff bezos and simon they
have so much influence on things that
should be the purview solely of the us
government how do you respond to that
maryland
that i think the u.s government does a
great job the nih has you know really
made the u.s
economy and the u.s research system the
powerhouse that it is
still
there were niches there are risks to
take
there's so there's a place for
philanthropy
for
you know those
out there ideas
um though
when i look at ligo i can only admire
the national science foundation
and its
incredible commitment and vision
to make that happen
um that's nothing that any private
philanthropist could do
but maybe just kind of
seeding initial ideas to help them get
to the level
that they'll be more attractive to the
government
um
you know there's there are niches i've
also heard from john holdren when we
went there
that
there are some things that are harder
for the government to do like
interdisciplinary research to bring
people in from across
fields
and so
there's a place to have an impact
but it's small i mean
in private philanthropy will always
hopefully be dwarfed by what the u.s
government does
but
i think that
we also try to work with the government
we do have some partnerships at the
simons foundation
with the national science foundation
so there's also a role to play to
supplement their efforts
so
yeah i think they like public private
partnerships
i think they do and now it's not only
percolating you know from traditional
partnerships you know faculty sabbatical
to uh you know
interdisciplinary collaborations between
private and public foundations at the
level of
nsf doe and beyond um i think you said
once the philanthropy should be like
venture capital
um which does combine your economic kind
of background and your scientific
philanthropy background i think that is
a great model and i heard you say once
you know that that foundation a small
foundation can be nimble and as wealthy
as the foundation might be or as how
many assets it's still pitifully small
compared to you know just what the
government spends in a single day um and
so if it can be the catalyst it can
nucleate collaborations it can catalyze
things and then that ultimately and you
can make a quick decision exactly and
that then allows the government to save
money which is what you know taxpayers
should be most appreciative of that the
foundation offsets the initial seed
capital that's needed to in this model
uh extend to uh to benefits to the
taxpayer of which you know you and i are
both members of the taxpaying public as
well i want to um you know conclude uh
with the existential questions that i
ask all my guests jim you can go back to
i'll have a link to jim's interview if
you want to
see how he answered it but i always ask
what i call the thrilling three final
questions that help get to uh
the core of who you are as a kind of a
heroine in this in the journey that
you've gone on in your life the
challenges the action the epiphanies the
climaxes that you've had in your life in
your career and i tie them in either
philosophically or technically to arthur
c clarke or the bible
and so if you're willing marilyn i would
love to ask you in the remaining couple
of minutes these thrilling three
questions would you mind answering and
going into the impossible
okay
okay let's do it okay the first one is
what would you put in your ethical will
not your material will ethical wills are
established since the time of you know
the ancients in the bible even alfred
nobel in his nobel prize
will he had a requirement that the nobel
prize go to those people who made the
world a better place the bettered
mankind and so i want to ask you what
kind of wisdom or thing knowledge have
you learned that you want to be queased
to your not just your biological
children but your ideological children
so
on my desk at the foundation
i had a sign
that
i made for
myself to look at
and um
it was actually a quote from plato
and it was
always be kind for everyone is fighting
a hard battle
and
i like that reminder
every day
just to
you know people matter
and to really
look at every person's humanness and
know
how we're all struggling
so
i use that
as a reminder for myself so i think i
would
definitely pass wanna pass that on just
be kind we're all having a hard time and
struggling yeah
indeed and uh the next question now goes
a little bit deeper into the future it
goes let's say a billion years into the
future and this is reminiscent of uh the
movie 2001 a space odyssey
where these monoliths these ominous
kinds of structures that seem to be like
time capsules
or perhaps their warnings or signs of
some kind
placed by an unseen alien civilization
maybe billions of years ago and they're
meant to be discovered maybe as a
testimony
to what they accomplished i want to ask
you
um in science
specifically and that you've been
exposed to everything from the life
sciences
autism science
physical sciences cosmology
quantum quantum mechanical systems
mathematics is there anything
that you feel
best encapsulates
the accomplishments that the
human species has accomplished the the
the most stunning or striking
accomplishment or accomplishments uh
that humanity has achieved in just the
short few hundred thousand years we've
made an impact on the plant
so when
you're talking about that
it kind of
reminds me of that
the
the movie or the play or
story about camelot
and
i know that there was that song
tell everyone
that there was once a
fleeting lisp of glory in camelot
and
you know camelot was about
trying to live together in perfect
harmony
and
i guess you talked about all these
sciences but
you know i can't take
credit for this i have to say
um that i heard jim once say that if
there's one science we haven't made a
lot of progress with it's political
science
and
i kind of you know i think we are
striving to learn to live in a world
where we could get along together
and
dealing with coronavirus
or climate change
that we're starting to see ourselves
more as the biosphere that we are
so
um i guess just learning to live
together in harmony with our planet with
each other with all the other living
things on this planet
um
is something that i i don't know how to
encapsulate that idea
except to see
that we aren't trying to do that and
science is helping us get there
to understand our role in our biosphere
so i i don't know what the short phrases
if it's learn political science or
or like you're part of the biosphere
and
learn how to make this work
i think that's where we have to go
wonderful okay marilyn the last question
uh will take us not to the future but to
your past sort of advice to your former
self and it's based on one of arthur c
clarke's laws he had all these different
laws
and he said the only way of
distinguished the only way of
discovering the limits of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible that's the origin
and the name of my podcast so i want to
accordingly ask you what mysterious
aspect of life perplexed you as a 20
year old or 30 year old and what kind of
lesson would you teach to her
to give her the courage to do as you've
done to go into the impossible is there
any advice to your former self you can
give
make a plan
i think
i um
you know
i once i was talking
giving a toast and about a mathematician
and
i learned that
some
some
mathematicians are mountains and some
are rivers
i think that i've lived my life more as
a river
going a little bit this way or that way
but
being a mountain i like
climbing to the top and seeing what's up
there when you get there
um
you know
a river has a little less of a plan
i think i make a plan
so
but my river took me to some wonderful
places indeed and hopefully
you're just getting started in this new
chapter in your journey and i just want
to relate uh a story you know of
possibly how maryland caused me to
become an astronomer and it relates back
to a time she was with me as a young
as a young boy i think i was four or
five my mom tells this story and i had
the croup
and it was very uh serious back then to
have the croup and you know every parent
knows the feeling of helplessness and
hopelessness
uh of a kid that's sick and how to take
care of him
and so my mom was uh you know was busy
with my my sibling my brother kevin
and so you took me out on a very cold
night in the middle of winter uh and you
said to me according to my mom that each
snowflake was a falling star
and it just mesmerized me and she
credits that with perhaps my interest in
astronomy and i think it's fitting that
as we know falling stars are uh
fragments of asteroids that fall to
earth
and i want to also remind people that
marilyn simons is the proprietor of
asteroid number 1070
marilyn simons
1981 pf discovered at harvard uh in 1981
it has many many fascinating
characteristics including the fact that
it can orbit inside the orbit of the
earth
and you can find out more information at
the minor planet center it was awarded
to marilyn simons american economist and
philanthropist she's she was i think you
were chair of the board of cold spring
harbor and you founded the stony brook
women's leadership council many things
fellowships
and was recently retired as the
president of the simons foundation and
she supports basic math science and
medical research around the world and is
now a member of the legend owner in
maryland i want to thank you so much we
love you we we have utmost respect and
gratitude for you in this holiday season
but throughout the year as well i want
to thank you for spending so much of
your valuable time with myself and my
audience today
well brian thank you and can i tell a
little story about you though
of course
and your family that
was like such an important part of my
life
and
the year i lived with you and your mom
and your brother when i was a grad
student
like i think that was transformative in
my life and i just loved the time that
we were all together
i just want to say
you know i spend a lot of time in
outreach
and
i
i don't know how you spark curiosity
that was a word you used a lot
and you were such a naturally curious
child i would be so amazed at things
that you knew when
there didn't seem to be anybody teaching
you these things
um but you would just dazzle me
with things that you would talk about
i remember one day in particular though
and
that your grandfather came to visit this
was your mother's
father
and he said to you and kevin
i want to go out on a safari and we
didn't you didn't live in africa you
lived on long island
and you're you all got you and kevin got
all bundled up to go out on a safari
with your grandfather
and when you came back
you had walked around
the neighborhood and just collected all
these things
that were natural around
leaves sticks
bugs cider whatever you could find
and
i that
stuart that
afternoon just stuck with me about just
going off and exploring your own
neighborhood
not to go you didn't have to fly across
the globe you didn't it was right there
there was so much to explore in your own
backyard and your own neighborhood
and um
you've really held on to a remarkable
sense of curiosity
and so much
more yeah
well thank you so much yeah it's funny
my motto on this channel is abc always
be curious
and i i find that is the most important
uh the most important tool you know
passion is great passion is kind of the
spark that ignites the rocket but you
need that fuel and i think curiosity can
sustain a lifelong passion
and hopefully use that to make the world
a slightly better place and you have
made my world a better place since i've
known you almost all my life and my
mother sends her away mutual
yes i want to just thank you for sharing
your time with us and my audience today
and i wish you the best of of health and
happiness in 2022 marilyn
all right same to you brian and to your
whole beautiful family thank you
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
you